[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 los más
vulnerables un programa sobre cómo esta
pandemia ha afectado a los cientos de
millones de personas que ya vivían en
situaciones de pobreza de hacinamiento o
de marginalidad o se veían obligadas a
emigrar o eran víctimas de guerras y
conflictos mi nombre es andrés suárez
jaramillo comenzamos en nueva york' en
la sede de la onu donde esta semana se
lleva a cabo la 75a asamblea general de
naciones en esta oportunidad en el marco
de la pandemia de kobe 19 mandatarios de
todo el mundo enviaron sus discursos
previamente grabados para componer una
cumbre virtual sin embargo quien sí lo
hizo desde el icónico anfiteatro de
nueva york fue el secretario general de
la onu antonio guterres su discurso
denunció graves problemáticas aunadas
por la pandemia y que deben ser tratadas
urgentemente escuchemos
el 19 ha puesto al descubierto las
fragilidades del mundo el aumento de las
desigualdades la catástrofe climática
las divisiones sociales cada vez mayores
la corrupción desenfrenada la pandemia
ha explotado estas injusticias se ha
aprovechado de los más vulnerables y ha
borrado el progreso de décadas
por primera vez en 30 años la pobreza
está aumentando los indicadores de
desarrollo humano están disminuyendo nos
estamos desviando del camino hacia el
logro de los objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible
antiguos guterres también habló sobre
cómo la pandemia de kobe 19 ha
repercutido en lugares de áfrica y medio
oriente donde ya se vivían guerras
civiles o conflictos armados y con lo
cual la hambruna se ha expandido entre
la población civil
en muchos lugares del mundo a la
pandemia junto con los conflictos y las
perturbaciones está dando golpes
devastadores a la seguridad alimentaria
millones de personas en la república
democrática del congo el noreste de
nigeria sudán del sur y yemen corren el
riesgo de sufrir de hambruna ahora es el
momento de un nuevo impulso colectivo
por la paz y la reconciliación
reconciliation finalmente guterres se
refirió al tema de género la pandemia
por cuenta los largos confinamientos en
el mundo ha elevado considerablemente
los casos de violencia intrafamiliar
contra niñas y mujeres según el
secretario de la onu se trata de una
guerra oculta que requiere del
compromiso de todos en la sociedad y más
con sus también debemos erradicar el
espirito su aumento de la violencia
contra las mujeres y las niñas durante
la pandemia desde la violencia doméstica
hasta el abuso sexual el acoso en línea
y el feminicidio esta es una guerra
oculta contra las mujeres prevenirla y
ponerle fin requiere el mismo compromiso
y los recursos con que nos dedicamos a
otras formas de guerra
warfare precisamente uno de los países
de los cuales habla el secretario
general de las naciones unidas es el
congo en el oriente de esta nación
africana los casos de violencia sexual
en contra de las mujeres aumentaron un
34 por ciento el año pasado una
problemática que afronta imelda en bab
una moto taxista que trabaja en un
gremio de hombres para apoyar a sus seis
hijos en una ciudad donde la mayoría de
la gente vive con menos de dos dólares
diarios esta es la historia
y male da mbabi recorre en moto las
calles polvorientas deben en el noreste
de la república democrática del congo en
el asiento trasero la acompaña una
clienta que se siente feliz de que el
trayecto lo haga una mujer ser
mototaxista no es común en un país donde
los hombres son quienes en mayoría
realizan este trabajo
mi esposa en julio y me dejó con seis
hijos nada para tortura no tenía nada
que hacer así que decidí convertirme el
mototaxista para alimentar a mis hijos
desde la muerte de su esposo hace diez
años imelda dejó de trabajar como
agricultora y dispuso sus ahorros para
comprarse la moto así mantiene a sus
hijos
el trabajo de mi madre nos ayudó a
conseguir comida educación ropa
medicinas y mucho más
también estoy orgulloso de su trabajo
porque crecí sin mi papá
y hoy estoy aquí gracias a su labor de
mototaxistas
pero ser mujer mototaxista conlleva
serios riesgos en un país donde
prevalece una insurgencia islamista
desde que terminó la guerra civil en
2003 una de las consecuencias ha sido la
cotidianidad de la violencia contra las
mujeres de hecho según una encuesta de
la fundación thomson reuters en 2018 el
congo es uno de los 10 países más
peligrosos del mundo para ser mujer
y tampoco la una vez que estaba viajando
desde el campo fue emboscada por
bandidos en la cola estaban vestidos con
ropas rojas manchadas de sangre y
querían hacerme daño pero cuando notaron
que era una mujer en una motocicleta se
pusieron muy nerviosos y me dejaron
continuar con mi viaje era su mamá
pero los viajes por el campo son los más
lucrativos por lo largo de los
recorridos y en la tuta tiza tapia claro
que nos preocupamos porque a veces mi
mamá se va a lugares lejanos sin
avisarnos así que nos molesta mucho
cuando llama para decirnos rita en el
camino datos son whatsapp
actualmente imelda prefiere transportar
a las mujeres de beni en lugar de los
hombres un trabajo que la enorgullece
pues desde que enviudó y comenzó su rol
de madre cabeza de familia ninguno de
sus seis hijos se ha ido a dormir con el
estómago vacío
en méxico una comunidad indígena
instalada en el sur del país y en lo
alto de una montaña del estado de
guerrero no tiene acceso a la educación
a pesar de que el gobierno de andrés
manuel lópez obrador decidió implementar
el nuevo año escolar con clases por
radio y televisión en esta remota zona
del país dicho programa es inviable no
hay señal mucho menos internet y a veces
ni siquiera electricidad pero los
locales buscan la manera para que sus
niños indígenas no se queden sin
educación esta es la historia
el cierre escuelas y colegios en méxico
ha dejado a miles de niños indígenas sin
posibilidad de estudio en un caso en
concreto es el del municipio de tlapa de
comonfort una población de 50 mil
personas de alta montaña en el estado de
guerrero donde aproximadamente el 82 por
ciento es indígena a este remoto paraje
me ha llegado con bastante dificultad el
plan educativo del gobierno aprende en
casa el cual busca que los niños no
interrumpan sus estudios y se formen por
medio de clases en televisión y radio a
través de la televisión a través del
internet no no es posible en la montaña
anda primeramente porque no hay no hay
computadoras no hay internet hay señal
de televisión y en segundo porque pues
éste está que también se va a la luz
en tiempo de lluvia en este esta
temporada de lluvia la luz se está yendo
constantemente y pues imagínense pues
con las dificultades técnicas y
tecnológicas los maestros se resisten a
abandonar a sus alumnos en la
empobrecida región indígena de méxico de
manera que cada 15 días se entregan
material educativo para
los padres adopten el rol de tutores y
enseñen diariamente a sus hijos pero
existe un impedimento muchos de ellos
sólo hablan el idioma natal de un xavi
una variante de la lengua indígena
mixteca cuando por lo mismo de que
estamos en una zona de alta marginación
y rezago educativo es porque muchos de
los padres de familia pues no lo saben
ni siquiera leer escribir y no no
entienden pues ellos se les dificulta
ahora cómo van a enseñar sus hijos si no
este si no saben lo que la letra pues
más que nada y no
- hablan en español como este municipio
de guerrero el 69.5 de la población
indígena en mexico es pobre en parte por
las denuncias de aislamiento y poca
atención del estado sin embargo el
despoblamiento y la incomunicación de
esta zona parece haber favorecido la
poca propagación del virus en trapa se
cuentan 293 casos de contagio y 44
muertes que afortunadamente son las
comunidades que tiene mayor filtro
sanitario son la comida
independientemente que sea la población
más pobre que digamos la población
la crisis del cobi 19 y su impacto en la
educación son solo un capítulo más del
largo historial de marginación de los
indígenas en méxico según cifras
oficiales más del 80 por ciento de los
niños indígenas sólo completan una
cuarta parte de la educación básica y
luego comienzan a trabajar
en brasil un sacerdote se enfrenta
abiertamente al presidente ya ir
bolsonaro el padre julio ancelotti
colecciona amenazas por su tarea de
ayudar a los más vulnerables que no
tienen techo en los barrios marginales
de sao paulo y por otra parte bolsonaro
lo denunció jurídicamente luego de que
en una homilía el padre lo hubiera
descrito como un machista racista y
homofóbico aquí la historia a sus 71
años juliol ancelotti es un sacerdote
que cumple tres décadas de haber
trabajado por alimentar a los sintechos
o indigentes en la ciudad de sao paulo
justo al finalizar la homilía de las
siete de la mañana empieza el ajetreo en
la parroquia de san miguel arcángel dos
voluntarios lo acompañan con mascarillas
comida y otros productos de primera
necesidad para ser repartidos en el
centro social de nuestra señora del buen
parto y con la pandemia todo se agravó
todo lo que era pobreza se agudizó las
personas no tienen trabajo y no tienen a
donde ir aumentó el número de personas
en la calle
según el último censo de la alcaldía de
sao paulo la ciudad registra unas 24 mil
344 personas en condiciones de calle de
manera que el padre trabaja para atender
a cerca de 500 sintechos diarios una
tarea por la cual ha sido tildado de
comunista un capitalismo humanista es
posible tener un capitalismo humanizado
yo creo que no yo creo que el
capitalismo no se humaniza al 10000
capitalismo por sí mismo es
deshumanizador desde un buen estado en
2017 en una de sus misas el padre
lancellotti criticó a yair bolsonaro
para entonces líder de extrema derecha
de quien dijo ser un machista racista y
homofóbico en contrapartida a
evolucionar o lo demandó un proceso que
aún sigue en curso pero que no ha
representado el riesgo de otras afrentas
en las cuales incluso ha sido víctima de
intentos de asesinato ya enfrente y
trapos de sol que bombas de gas
yo ya enfrenté tropas de choque bombas
de gas violencia y fui agredido por la
policía que la policía
ya tentar un imán ya me intentaron matar
varias veces entonces como dice el
refrán si sales a la lluvia es para
mover de visto inyectado keith saint al
sur de brasilia entre 2015 y 2019 el
número de personas que viven en la calle
se disparó un 60 por ciento en la
capital paulista
paradójicamente el trabajo social del
padre lancellotti es mal visto por los
políticos en su contra pesa una campaña
difamatoria por parte de uno de los
candidatos a la alcaldía de sao paulo de
cara a las elecciones municipales de
noviembre
artur do val quien le calificó del
proxeneta de la miseria pero la
ancelotti no se rinde y batalla a diario
contra la desigualdad
este es el panorama de los más
vulnerables de esta semana en el mundo
ante el coronavirus organismos
internacionales y gobiernos están
anunciando paquetes de ayuda pero son
miles de millones las personas que
enfrentan esta pandemia en frágiles
condiciones y el alivio sólo es relativo
gracias por seguirnos recuerde que más
información la puede encontrar en
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
[Música]